hey guys how's it going it's Justine
welcome back to my kitchen and today
it's st. Patrick's Day and to celebrate
I am making my inspiration my reason for
living I am making grilled cheese
sandwiches now I've made these before I
made a grilled cheese Tower back in the
day and that was the first time that I
got to use this little griddle here oh
yeah baby
but today we're gonna make it special
we're gonna make them green now I don't
know if this is gonna work at all I
actually don't know what to expect as
per usual I've seen so many people
making the rainbow grilled cheeses so I
thought hey why not try to make it green
I don't really know what's gonna happen
so let's just get started the first
thing that these guys are bred we've got
some butter and of course most
importantly some green of food coloring
you are the key ingredients to this
recipe oh geez
I need cheese since I have to go with a
nice mild cheddar do you do you like
cheese I like toast intolerant so
probably won't be having any of this
today I need to melt the butter and make
the butter green so with our butter
we're gonna put in a little just you
know okay well I was gonna say a little
bit of food dye but that's a lot we're
gonna put this in microwave add a minute
now there we go we're cooking here's the
problem the green food dye is
splattering everywhere
[Music]
this is very hot I think I'm gonna turn
it down oh my god my phone is burning
let me see that breath
oh I stabbed it cut the flutter watch
there it is that is definitely something
that I've don't really ever want to see
again
this is repulsive so here's the problem
I think I probably should use a
different type of dye it's too late so
ponds okay now we're gonna probably make
the same mistake course it's all up here
because why would it not be accessible
somewhere that it's easy to get Wow
I found some cans of pumpkin from two
pumpkins pumpkins ago huh
these are definitely expired this is
what I've been looking for my cake this
wasn't what I was looking for but my
cake leveler that's something I need yes
do you know what this is I think this
might be made for like not for someone
taller should have been abolished okay
what am I even doing I was looking for
green food coloring that was gel and
whatever pain in my ceiling did a very
bad job of it I'm getting a whole new
perspective on my life
my house definitely my lack of memory
retention because okay why am I here why
are any of us here here catch this is
something I've been looking for that
does not belong here
so absolutely nothing was accomplished
this butter is looking disgusting now
we're gonna melt our cheese probably
should a Google just do what everybody
else did and just stole their ideas but
I'm gonna do my own idea so I'm gonna
just melt this cheese into my own
mixture and I'm going to pour it in
between two slices of bread
[Music]
I think I'm gonna put this on like a
lower power setting because they feel
like it's going to burner and we do not
want that to happen and we're gonna see
how this works out
yes it looks amazing you just thump it
this is not something that you should
ever try we gotta get all the way to the
edges so I remember back when I was
little I think I was probably in
kindergarten and they let you see what
do you wanna be when you grow up I said
I wouldn't to be a chef I don't know why
I never liked cooking and Here I am many
many years later I'm doing my childhood
dream yeah why that was my childhood
dream because I didn't ever like I never
liked cooking I think I just got nervous
so let's flip this over
oh my cheese boy olena cuz we're gonna
mix this cheese up a little more
don't try anything HomeGoods and if you
do try it do not tell your parents that
I just seen this was her idea because it
was not her idea I will not be taking
any angry phone calls or emails from
your parents a flipper doodle-doo this
is definitely mixing much better are you
making fun of me look at this cheese
can you guys believe this this is
perfect this is actually exactly what I
was hoping I was it was gonna happen
this is unreal
this is so great oh god wait I have to
eat this I'm just gonna get that nice
and all on to the edges just like so how
do you touch how to touch house you
touch okay I'm gonna give it a flip cuz
I don't know what is happening on this
other side oh I can't wait to show you
guys the surprise that I have for you
the nice fun little addition to this so
because I have some of this leftover dye
I made something ahead of time because
it wasn't quite sure if it was gonna
work or not
I made shamrock butter little things I
mean I don't know why you would ever do
this but so using the green butter
you've got a little green shamrock
butter isn't that cute this is not
healthy at all this is slime this is the
new challenge it's the cheese challenge
I challenge someone to eat all no don't
eat that I'm not I want to be the one
that starts that this has got to go away
I can never see this again well now you
guys know what it's time for it's time
for slo-mo cheese taste tests let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god it's so good I mean this thing
is doused in butter filled with
delicious melted cheese
if only you were not this disgusting
green color oh my god I'm so happy right
now
I really never felt this from happiness
I need Jenna to try it because she's got
to taste this it is phenomenal you want
me to eat that it's so good like ice Oh
Jenna I already have and I or of it play
the play so good put it down your gullet
are gonna have some toilet trouble just
take a bite I swear it's the best it
tastes so good but I don't want it to be
just eat it the middle middle part of it
oh don't look at it
Oh again very soon yeah why are you
happy you're not green well I've eaten a
lot of this this is not healthy alright
guys well thanks so much for watching
this is by far something that you should
never make because it is dangerous it is
dangerous for the health standards the
environment I don't even want to see
this later but I'm definitely going to
I'll see you guys later as well bye
[Music]
you